[musique]
son agrandisseur Wagner Oui, il a fini dans
50 mètres d'eux, c'est vrai, c'est vrai, c'est
il a posé des mines antipersonnel
Et
c'est eux ils les ont déjà mis ils s'éloignaient
ils ont été remarqués par ce drone de reconnaissance et ils
ils ont été abattus à l'artillerie
[musique]
vue à ce sujet j'ai personnellement des copines
enfance, qui a quitté Donetsk pour la Russie
ils se taisent ils comment c'est arrivé quoi
c'est arrivé je suis généralement pour le monde c'est comme ça
J'ai peur, j'ai pitié des gens, arrête, arrête
mais je ne me sens pas désolé pour moi
avoir pitié de l'homme qui est venu avec une arme
dans mon pays et tué mon mari
[musique]
la première fois que j'ai essayé d'appeler
quelque part à quelqu'un pour me trouver personne
n'ai rien dit le 31 au soir je
J'ai trouvé une photo sur Internet en russe
site Internet
Où est mon mari couché dans une camionnette avec un déchiré
pied
11 4 mois
plus assis ou 60 ans et une amitié comme ça
[musique]
jusqu'à la fin tu ne peux pas t'en rendre compte
On dirait que tu viens de me parler hier
l'homme aujourd'hui il n'est plus là et accepte
cela ne peut être traité et
apprends à vivre
[musique]